don't let me please oh please
take
bloodborne is a darksouls follow-up in
all but name but it's too different to
be called a mere copy blood-borne is not
short of mysteries but its story beats
are inescapable the souls games led you
through parishes and cathedrals but
never have they made such grand
statements with their subject matter
only now has developer from software
allowed an extravagant religious parable
to mirror its death and resurrection
mechanics but that the holy medium of
blood healing is venerated in the main
cathedral outside of this clear theming
the developing saga comes to life
through the sights and sounds of its
world blood-borne sucks the faith hope
and charity from religious devotion
populating its world with grotesque
disciples and forcing the meek into
their homes
what born is not nuanced its unafraid to
go big to the extent that you may find
yourself saying to yourself did that
really just happen that it's malformed
majesty worked so well as blood warns
greatest feat as with the souls games
however blood-borne doesn't typically
tell you where to go and what to do when
you get there you're given a few vague
overarching goals but the intricately
interconnected regions and pathways
along with nebulous visual cues lead you
to your destination thankfully this
world is one worth knowing and knowing
well after blood-borne soaks you in its
Victorian London look it introduces
greater graphical diversity blood-borne
tells a story with its environments as
you press onward echoing its plot with
its architecture and its enemies there's
a blight on this town in the form of
seriously long loading times and
occasional framerate foibles but it's
worth powering through the occasional
technical problems blood-borne is a joy
to play both in how it cribs from the
souls games as well as in how it
deviates from them
your souls combat skills apply to
blood-borne but only to a certain extent
if you relied on a shield to defend you
in the past you won't find the shoddy
shield you discover in blood-borne to be
of much use to you the game demands
mobility avoidance is imperative lest a
group of demon dogs tear your flesh
apart while leaving you powerless to
slash your way out of danger yet
slashing away as a compelling response
due to blood-borne health regain system
should you take damage you have a
limited time to gain some of that lost
vitality by landing hits of your own the
system may strike you is incompatible
with the rhythms of typical Souls combat
but it's a wonderful fit in blood-borne
you see your foes are just as agile even
the Hulk's that descend upon you in
blood-borne x' boss battles boss arenas
are typically large affording you plenty
of room to escape the wrath of the
horror staring you down and affording
that horror the same luxury circle
strafing can no longer be your deep
strategy when the enemy proves more
limber than you these might seem like
small adjustments to the formula but
they changed the way you applied
fundamental skills like when and when
not to lock on to your enemies you can
carry a firearm in your left hand though
it makes for a poor offensive weapon
that's not just because it's tuned more
for staggering enemies than for damaging
them but also because ammunition is a
finite resource there's no spell
spamming equivalent in blood-borne
though a rifle or blunderbuss makes a
fine accompaniment to whatever blade you
wield in your right hand that melee
weapon by the way is transformable a
cleaver for instance is great for doing
close rapid damage but it's secondary
mode extends its reach at the cost of
speed and transforming during active
battle delivers a third type of attack
as the weapon morphs from one state to
the other
as expected blood-borne can be brutal
not as hard as Dark Souls or demon souls
but a step above Dark Souls 2 in its
level of difficulty as a result mastery
requires properly reacting to enemy
behavior understanding how much space
you must put between you and your prey
and knowing when and when not to exploit
health regeneration blood-borne also
takes the survival horror aspects of its
close cousins to new heights some
enemies aren't just terrifying because
of their size their power but because of
the hideous sounds they make and the
shocking entrances that jolt you out of
your trance
from software continues to break the
rules of videogame adventuring to
fantastic effect blood-borne kills you
again and again and inspires you to
venture once again into the same
territory in hope of regaining the blood
echoes you lost their help arrives in
the form of other players which you see
as spirits in your own world you can
also drop spectral messages on the
ground alerting other players to traps
and other dangers there are interactions
in the form of direct cooperation ring
the right bell in your inventory and
you'll either summon a helper to your
world or signal your availability to
others it's always wonderful to have
someone to distract another gargantuan
boss while you sprint and to damage it
from behind these multiplayer components
are also available in blood-borne
chalice dungeons which are procedurally
generated adventuring areas that you
enter by performing a ritual on the hub
world which is called hunter's dream
standalone dungeons are a neat idea but
there are too many caveats to make them
as worthwhile as you'd expect there are
specific bosses in there to defeat such
as a humungous flaming watchdog but if
you don't periodically perform new
chalice rituals you can out level the
ones available to you and breeze through
them which isn't much fun I also
encountered numerous bugs and chalice
dungeons like getting stuck in place and
glitchy boss behavior the finest
treasures are not found within the
chalice dungeons but within the city of
yharnam and the forests lakes and
predatory beyond it
I finished blood-borne in a little less
time than I did Dark Souls 2 maybe 60
hours or so but I treasure it more
knowing that there are many secrets I
never uncovered keeps me coming back now
at level one oh one and three bosses
into a new game plus I have no intention
of stopping